hi my name is Justin Pearson I'm a
graduate student in electrical and
computer engineering at University of
California at Santa Barbara and I taught
a class in intro to programming for
engineers and all sorts of different
engineers take this class mechanical or
chemical electrical and they would
always stumble we taught this class in
MATLAB they would always stumble at
certain points in the class because they
had to contort their thinking into a
form that MATLAB could understand so for
instance with ordinary differential
equations you can't just tell MATLAB to
solve the differential equation you have
to boil down the nth order equation into
a vector first-order equation you have
to make a separate M file that encodes
the right-hand side you have to call
this specially named function that has
some weird numbers in it and it's really
confusing for students because it
doesn't look like anything like what
they learned in their math classes so I
took one day I told them you know there
are other programming languages out
there and I showed them in the Wolfram
language how you can solve a
differential equation with a single line
and then you can plot out the the
solution to that equation and look at
and get all sorts of physical insight
from it that you wouldn't have if you
just got a pile of numbers from MATLAB
and I had some friends in the audience
who said that when they sauce to
students reactions to this the students
were awestruck by the the ability of the
Wolfram language to solve a really
complicated math problem without having
to go through the rigmarole that they
would have had to do in MATLAB they came
up to me afterwards after this
presentation and some of them had their
laptops in hand and they were logged on
to the Wolfram programming lab getting
started for the first time and they were
just so thrilled that instantly they
could in their browser get started
learning this new language and making
their lives and engineering careers a
lot easier